- What's up, you guys?
It's Jay Mendoza.
- It's Nameless James.
And um, where are we?
- We're in Sunnyside, California,
in L.A. at Dodger Stadium.
It's 2022 Home Run Derby.
What are we doing?
- Well, we're competing
for home run balls,
me versus him.
And I can tell you,
I have no concerns about
who's gonna win this.
- They say talk is cheap.
You know what I'm saying?
- Again, not concerned.
- Who's gonna get this W? Let's go.
- Let's go.
I actually have no idea
where we're going, though.
- Are we in the left pavilion
or right pavilion?
Let's just go into the bleachers.
Come on.
- Wow.
- You see,
it's the field.
Everybody who comes up
to me, I'm gonna just
tell 'em you gotta help me.
Hey, we need your help though.
How many we catching?
- All of them.
- All of 'em?
- So if you catch all of 'em,
just gimme one.
- I'll give you half.
- I gotta catch as many of those balls
as I can.
- All right.
- All right?
She's going barehand.
- I don't give a [beep].
- Why you got a glove?
Give her the glove.
- Yeah.
- Hey, Mendoza on 3.
1, 2, 3.
- [All:] Mendoza!
- What it seems is gonna
benefit me is talking to
the people that recognize me.
All right, let's take this picture.
So hopefully with Jack,
nobody recognizes him.
Do winners on 3.
1, 2, 3.
- Winner! Hey, right here, baby.
- Hey, not you!
Get the heck outta here.
- I want feedback on my thought process.
I'm thinking everyone's crowding here.
- Yes.
So I feel like a lot of balls
are gonna be hit here.
- Yeah.
- So I feel like if you stand back here,
you have more move, room to move around.
- That's right.
- You know, if any, any little ricochets,
you can get 'em.
Can I come down there?
Oh wait. Bro, this mic just,
this cam just fell off.
I might have misplaced my 360 cam.
- So we just got the word
that Jack lost his 360 camera.
He's already losing this game.
- I feel like I gotta stretch, dude.
Come on, we gotta stretch.
We got, we gotta run for some balls.
- We gotta be fast, bro.
Warming up.
I'm warming up.
Hey, we're gonna get a ball, right?
We're gonna get one, right?
We're gonna get one.
- Hell yeah. That's right.
- Derby time, baby.
[Crowd cheering]
Oh [beep].
I'm ready to see some home runs.
[Upbeat rock music]
[Crowd cheering]
Hey, that was crazy!
Hey baby! Hey, hey, Southside.
Yeah, nice one, baby.
We were right, though.
We were right.
- Man, the chances out here are
one out of thousands.
[Buzzer]
Oh! Hey, he got a ball!
You wanna sell it?
Come on,
what we doing?
Let's sell it.
Come on.
- Let's see what these guys are doing.
Is Corey Seager a lefty?
- Do you guys know who's up next?
- Seager.
- Hey, right field, let's go.
Hey, that was a lot of balls that get
caught over there, but, empty.
I don't know where to go right here.
Gotta go in there.
[Upbeat rock music]
- Fuuudge!
- Come on, Seager. I'm a Dodger fan.
Come on.
[Crowd cheering]
So I'm not doing that.
Hey.
You wanna sell that real quick?
- [Beep] no.
- Aw damn!
As you guys can see,
I need help.
- Jay's not quick enough.
He's not like this.
This is way harder than I thought.
If you're in the crowd with people,
like, even if it's right to you,
you gotta battle for those.
Whereas if you're in a general
vicinity just around them,
you could react better, right?
[Crowd cheering]
[Hip-hop beats]
He's got it, he's got it,
he's got it, he's got it!
Oh, here we go. Here we go!
Are you kidding me?
I'm getting antsy. I need a ball.
- [Announcer:] That one's got a chance.
- I need a pretty good spot to be.
[Crowd screaming]
No!
God!
- All right, we gotta
try to get a ball, all right?
- No, we're gonna get one.
- Hey, get this guy outta here.
- Hey, my dad's in the home run seats.
He has like three balls already.
- Tell him to give me one so I can win.
- I don't care what happens.
He's not getting a ball.
I will tackle him to the ground
and rip it out of his mitt.
- Hey, go chase some balls, bro.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
[Bell chiming]
- [Laughing]
We got one ball.
- He's a fraud.
Check the watermark.
That ball was brought into this game.
- 1-0.
- [Announcer:] He's got four on the board.
- I don't know if we
stay here or if we move.
This is so much harder than
I thought it was gonna be.
- I wonder if I could go down there
with the credentials.
So if we could try to get down there.
- All right,
so here's what we're gonna do.
We've been trying.
We're gonna refuel, get some water,
maybe a little snack.
Everyone's saying
I gotta try a Dodger Dog.
- We got one step closer, so.
- If you wanted, if you want more,
that's where he's hitting most of 'em,
on that side.
- OK. OK.
- I don't know.
Should I get a Dodger Dog?
Like, I feel like I have to.
Um, I think I might do
a Dodger Dog, please.
[Upbeat rock music]
- Ohhh! Oh, ha ha!
Hey, do you wanna sell that to me?
- No.
- No? How much you want?
I'll send you 350 right now.
Oh, so you already got one.
- During batting practice.
Oh! I dropped my ball!
- Thank you.
- Thanks.
All right.
Let's find some condiments.
Oh, what is this?
Elote? Damn,
that looks so good.
[Background chatter]
All right.
[Crowd exclaiming]
- Hey, I thought it was gonna hit you.
I got you, I got you,
I got you.
- You got it.
- Expensive camera equipment here.
Look at this,
look at this. Watch out.
Oh.
Oh!
[Clang]
[High-energy music]
[Bell chiming] Yeaaahh! Yeah!
We got a ball! Yeah! [Laughing]
We got a ball!
I can't believe I caught a ball.
Caught a ball.
Hold on, let me call my wife.
I got a ball.
Jack, I'm sorry. You lost, bro.
- This is tough.
I just gotta like, throw,
throw my glove up there.
All these people catching balls.
- Let's go!
- No way.
No way.
How you feeling right now,
by the way?
- Pretty great for sure.
- Amazing. You got two, dude.
- Hey. Juan Soto to the Padres.
- Getting real, real down.
Motivation, morale is low.
- [Announcer:] Final minute of the T-Mobile Home Run Derby.
[Crowd noise]
- What a day.
What a day.
I wonder what Jay's up to.
Probably paying people to
give him balls. Like a poser.
I'll give him this one.
- The champ is here.
- I'll give him this one.
- Came out on top.
- Hey.
- I'm happy that Jay won at home.
- Dude, it's all right.
- Next Derby.
- It was great effort.
Great effort.
- I'll know to start paying people.
- [Laughing]
Did I lose my money?
[Laughing]